[Music]
babies babies babies what's up it's me
you remember me I'm saying that cuz I
back in LA and I'm doing my podcast here
now back home and I was doing it in
Toronto I did it twice in Toronto and I
never quite understood uh I didn't know
anybody out there in Toronto and it was
weird how boring it was for me I love to
run I'm not trying not to city it was
[ __ ] amazing
but it was also raining every day and so
I wanted to jump out of the window
because I hate the rain and I also hate
when people say they like the rain that
bugs me when people are like oh you know
I but I love the rain because then you
get to be inside and it's all cozy and
you sit near the fireplace okay then you
don't like the rain if you like if you
were if you like to rain you'll be out
in the rain
you don't say people who love the beach
go to the beach
they don't [ __ ] sit inside and think
about the beach or hear the beach you
don't like the rain if you don't go out
in the [ __ ] rain so if you say you
like the rain go out in the rain and and
[ __ ] dance around and [ __ ] otherwise
don't say you don't like the rain you
like being inside then oh then you like
being inside so [ __ ] this Rain Man it
was insane bad I mean like it was like a
monsoon or anything but it just never
stopped it stopped for like one day and
so I was getting fed up of it because I
couldn't do cool [ __ ] in Toronto I
couldn't even like go to like I mean I
don't ever really do cool [ __ ] but like
my buddy invited me to the Toronto
Blue Jays game and I was like that
course not um and but uh but yeah so I
would just like go to the Starbucks and
get [ __ ] Starbucks and I was bored
out of my mind but like not but I don't
I was just talking about this earlier on
the other podcast i don't i don't i
think boring people get bored right but
like man it was weird but then i came
back to LA and I did the same thing that
I did in Toronto and I [ __ ] was not
bored so I don't know maybe it's like
I'm just I don't know what that means
really I don't know what that means I
think it was the option to do whatever I
wanted to do is what makes me not bored
which is [ __ ] weird because I'm just
I'm still not doing it it's a mindset
thing dude but I was there for two and a
half weeks didn't have friends you know
but so this is the fifteenth episode
we're doing we were close we're getting
close to a hundred guys and then we're
going to be in syndication so I'm back
in LA and by the way it was so hot when
I wasn't in LA able to tell me are you
missing it you missed it and I get back
to LA the second I get back to LA it
rains literally and it's freezing and I
[ __ ] I can't stay with people like
yeah you brought the rain with you you
know hey you brought the rain with you I
shut up you're just saying you know what
you're saying blah lulala lulala oh
you're saying that cuz that's just
something to say and you're wasting time
let's get to the good [ __ ] how's your
dick or something you know how's your
[ __ ] um dude I can't believe when I
recorded this last podcast episode 14
that I [ __ ] did it while the Met Gala
gala was going on and then when I stop
recording everyone was like tweeting me
about the Met Gala and I [ __ ] now I'm
a little weak laid on the Met Gala look
man uh it raises a money for fat for
fashion or whatever the [ __ ] it raises
money for which is great it's always
good to raise money for some [ __ ]
causes and and and when I I went on a
what do you call it a rant on Twitter
about it about how stupid it what
everyone looked and everyone was like
you don't get it you don't get it they
were dressing to the theme okay oh
really
cool oh that's cool also they look dumb
also they look done cool I understand
there's a theme also they look dumb
that's it that's all I'm trying to say a
lot of people dress to the theme also
and didn't look dumb but the people who
got all the [ __ ] press and all that
[ __ ] looked really [ __ ] dumb
Pharrell's wife look like this side of a
goddamn couch okay am I supposed to sit
on your Pharrell's wife no really then
show me your arms did you see her
[ __ ] outfit they had no arms what
happens if she got a scratch on her
[ __ ] face
Pharrell better be there dude to scratch
your [ __ ] face that's so weird
I'm putting that [ __ ] on it had norms
she put it over her head
it looks stiff as [ __ ] had no arms and
[ __ ] for I was like you ready let's
go and for all just wore a leather
jacket and jeans what a dick making his
wife [ __ ] wear a couch and he [ __ ]
put on just jeans and a leather jacket
and he was like let's go um I mean the
[ __ ] her outfit was suicide wrist red
it was a red look at the red couch was
suicide wrist red soft color suicide
rich wrist red hey dude I want red but I
want it to be the most depressing thing
of all time
suicide wrist red oh um so anyway and by
the way I there was a picture of
Pharrell with like a bunch of the amigos
guys and [ __ ] and I was making fun how
they look like they were from the matrix
and [ __ ] Pharrell looked like dressed
like my dad compared to them how do you
how does Pharrell look like the normal
guy in the picture so the Met Gala was
are horrible I mean it's great it's
great that it but you know it's great
that it but like stop giving these
people [ __ ] and I'm here's the other
thing I'm tired of I made fun of Rihanna
like for dressing like origami but like
this is the thing I said on Twitter is
just because somebody is so good at what
they do
Katy Perry I think she's a great singer
I think rihanna is a great singer and a
great artist but that doesn't mean that
they [ __ ] don't look like [ __ ]
when they dress like trash I mean
[ __ ] Katy Perry literally had I think
the levels are [ __ ] too high on this
I don't know Katy Perry literally had
rearview mirrors on her face she had to
[ __ ] rearview mirrors on her face
like those spy glasses where you could
see behind that you could buy when you
were a kid if you sent away for a bunch
of things after eating a bunch of
Nabisco crackers dude she had rear view
mirrors on her face hey Katy Perry
evokes wagon
oh no you human then take those rearview
mirrors off your [ __ ] face great
singer but don't pretend because she's a
great singer that she slayed clean she
didn't she dressed like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I get it was the theme but
she dressed like an [ __ ]
and so did Rihanna Rihanna looked like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not she's dude she's
beautiful she's great at her job but
that doesn't mean she can dress and
maybe she can dress I mean she's looked
amazing before but she got look too
carried away oh and then somebody was
like look at the theme I looked up the
theme it was caught it was like the
in-between nests of fashion or whatever
that's anything man
I could put a condom over my [ __ ]
head and be like hey I'm in-between
[ __ ] sex and fashion or whatever the
[ __ ] and people would take pictures
every on I did that people would have
been like oh she Slade Queen I [ __ ]
hate that dude hey oh my god she shut it
down no you didn't you're on your couch
you know just chill you need to say
anything
just chill hey she shut down [ __ ] the
Met Gala now it still happened she
didn't shut [ __ ] down she looks like a
[ __ ] a bunch of barnacles on a
[ __ ] sea stump or one of those
[ __ ] dock things that hold up the
dock that's what she looked like she had
a bunch of [ __ ] like gay barnacles on
her because there were all different
colors and here comes people mad at me
because I said that kids say [ __ ] at
anything gay barnacles yo we're for Gabe
barnacles and actually it's not cool
because it's not cool to assume that
Barnack some barnacles want to [ __ ] the
same sex barnacles as the other
barnacles want to [ __ ] different sex
barnacles okay Met Gala was stupid as
[ __ ] people look good like
what's-his-name look good Jake
Gyllenhaal was very look good
rami malek is that his name he looked
good and [ __ ] donald glover look good
he went little pushed a little bit but
it looked good you look like a bunch of
gay barnacles pi I was in Toronto and I
was uh I was chillin and I was like
thinking about my buddy who my buddy uh
he's an actor he's a little dramatic but
he's always he's always telling me like
yeah man I miss you man and like I would
say like I miss you back and I really I
was thinking about him and I while I was
in Toronto and I was like dude I [ __ ]
don't miss him you know and then I was
thinking about what the [ __ ] missing
means like what then I was really trying
to [ __ ] figure that out like what is
a miss what is that and so I started
thinking about like my dad and like do I
miss my dad it's been two and a half
weeks and like and then when does that
[ __ ] miss start kicking in and what
is even that what is that is it a
feeling it's like a feeling of you
missing someone I don't know what that
is ma'am this is why I started to think
I was a [ __ ] sociopath because like
yeah do I want do I like hanging out
with my friends yeah I like hanging out
with with people that I love but when
I'm not with them I don't know if I feel
like I miss them I wonder if people
identify with this like I don't know
what the [ __ ] that means
you know like in movies like whenever a
guy misses a girl if she died of cancer
or whatever like they show like they
show flashbacks and he's in the bed with
her like hiding under the covers and the
sun's peeking in and it's like this
really sigur rós type music and you're
like oh he must miss her and she's dead
now I guess that's what it is like if I
cry I miss somebody seroma if I if my
eyes rain do I miss someone um
but I don't know dude I used to do this
bit on stage where I was like pissed me
off about how every movie about robots
robots knew how to do everything
except say crying and they'd be like why
are your eyes raining like dude you they
know how to say crying are you
programmed every [ __ ] uh word ever
except for crying you skip to that one
and it says why are your eyes raining
yeah why are your eyes raining I think
they said that in like Bicentennial man
or some [ __ ] why are your eyes
raining it's called crying crying what
is crying it is when your eyes rain yes
why do you cry do you cry when you miss
someone oh and then at the end of the
[ __ ] movie the robots like you are
crying and then you're supposed to cry
he's like oh he learned crying but I
don't really know man I don't know I
guess I like seeing the people I love
but like what is that like sitting and
thinking about somebody dude I I really
honestly want to know I don't really get
it I think that's so that's so like
sociopathic I don't know um anyway my
buddy what I'm trying to say is I did I
don't miss my buddy but I like hanging
out with him you know what I was
thinking about like what I what I what I
and this is how I finally [ __ ]
started to identify with it I was
thinking about like how like oh [ __ ]
when when I go on the road I take like
two or three at the most pairs of shoes
and I was like [ __ ] man I wish I had all
my shoes like is that missing cuz if
that's missing if I don't miss people
and I miss my shoes that I'm a hooker do
you understand cause hookers don't
[ __ ] have like real love in their
life you know probably like on a general
basis but they love like Louboutin you
know that's how I am I'm a hooker
basically because I was like thinking
about my shoes and wanting to put them
on like adidas and Jordans and Yeezys
and [ __ ] like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's bad dude and I was
thinking about also why I like shoes so
much
that's a weird thing because like I
don't like like pants or like shirt so
much I feel like degli because like I
get it from my dad my dad had wears like
red shoes sometimes you know and like
you
be like anybody's got like black outfit
on but like red shoes that he designed
from Nike ID like a [ __ ] 70 year old
and and he's like well I like it because
like it's the one article of clothing as
a guy you can kind of go out there with
but not [ __ ] you know be too much and
I was like dude that's exactly that's
exactly why I like [ __ ] shoes you
know I got regular jeans on right now I
got my [ __ ] hoodie on and I got my ez
song and their orange the easiest have a
little orange in him I would not wear
that color orange on my body yeah but I
usually bring the most user-friendly
shoes that'll just go with anything like
I have [ __ ] black Nikes that I bring
the black black cyber monday Jordans oh
because I could wear on the one I was on
when I'm on the plane or whatever and
just be comfortable with dude this guy
on the plane was hilarious on the way
back he was this [ __ ] Australian guy
first of all that sat next to me and
super nice but we didn't talk much we
didn't talk at all really but like was
he was in first class live in it up man
this guy was just all the perks like
when they come by like who the [ __ ] like
okay I guess like like okay like the the
stewardess would come by and be like do
you want a paper which paper would you
like and they had that like the USA
Today in the Canadian Times or whatever
the [ __ ] they call it and then like in
New York Times and like Los Angeles
Times and he was like Yale Tiger paper
and he took the paper and then [ __ ]
he was reading the paper just living it
up and that's fine you want the
newspaper you want the newspaper it's
boring on a flight whatever and then
they came by and was like hey what do
you want to eat and he was like I'll
have the cod all over the loin the loin
the lawn of the code and so we got the
cod loin which is like living it up you
know like they had barbecue chicken and
a vegetable dish and [ __ ] cod loin
and that's the most so livin it up
[ __ ] I mean if you're in first class
and you get the cod and there's a
barbecue chicken option you're so living
it up I mean you're the [ __ ] king of
first-class you looking at the whole
plane you're the pilot basically so she
was like okay cool and then I was like
I'll get the [ __ ] cod lon - because I
didn't want this [ __ ] to be
showing me up on what the [ __ ] I was
going to be eating right so I got the
[ __ ] card line because the Australian
was getting the cod line
it was good anyway but then they came
back and they were like and what would
you like to drink and he was like da da
lock sparkling water and like which is
like living it up like that's basically
water for the plebeians transformed into
the [ __ ] celeb ended up version so
now the guys got no regular water but
the most saliva dedup version he's got
the [ __ ] wince the the water that
transform that [ __ ] eat our with
bubbles on it and now [ __ ] he's
rolling out with the [ __ ] water and
she says would anybody care for some
wine and I don't drink so I was like no
thanks and he says yeah I'd like em look
on a warranty if I like him what I'd
like is that would he have light and
would he ever read and she was like oh
we just have kind of whatever and he
says I'll get his shot and I Sliven it
up and then she was like well we don't
have Chardonnay and he was like I will
you go and she just holds up like the
two bottles of wine that she had she's
like what no first first she said you
want red or white wine and he was like
I'll take his [ __ ] and I she's like we
don't have Chardonnay and so and then it
would like it took way too long for her
to be like here are the options we have
which were two bottles one red and one
white and then he was like and he
grabbed the white bottle from her and he
looked and he read the label he was
reading the label in on a plane so
living it up with the cod loin in front
of him holding a wineglass reading the
label and he looks and he says oh yeah
you know what I had this last time yeah
this is very drinkable
if you describe anything that you drink
as a very drinkable immediately I want
to [ __ ] my pants and leave it there for
40 minutes okay yeah you know what dude
that's why it's designed as a drink
because it's drinkable nothing is very
drinkable you understand me it's only
one level of drinkable okay you can you
can say a milkshake is hard to drink but
you don't say something that is a an
actual regular drink is very drinkable
with
now getting me BRM okay I was blood man
blood red man and so he says it all have
this is very drinkable and she was like
okay she had to pretend like it was like
oh yeah oh of course it is you know so
she pours it gives it back to him
it gives it to him and then leaves a
little bit and he takes a few sips of
his very drinkable why was so drinkable
that he took a few sips already and then
she comes back and he says you know what
this doesn't last time I had this Sam it
didn't taste like this it tastes a
little bit different um can I have can I
send it back he sends back the BA the
wine he sends it back dude like he's at
a restaurant called in reflections he
sends it back and then he gets the red
wine and he's all have the other one and
he drinks the red wine and then he's
happy eating the cod loin sent the wine
back because it wasn't drinkable enough
and then got the red wine and while he's
drink while he's reading the USA Today
livin it up Hey Dude are you P Diddy
oh dude where are you where are you you
can only be like that if you're on the
way to P Diddy's white party and he
wasn't because he was dressed in all
colors dude it was so funny every time
you ordered in under my breath I went
sniffing it up to nobody it was like
this guy always heard this in his head
no matter where he was being many won't
you take me to pin when you funky down
boom any point you take me to be a punk
it down been ipanema pain oh oh no anal
Anna and he was like Al of the warlord
is very drinkable being painting penny
pumping oh no burner pin pin pin pin pin
pin oh yeah I'll take all the newspapers
let me send this one back and I love the
chord line penny pimp into me
would you take me to Funkytown beneath
people pin yeah you know I mean this guy
was going from [ __ ] Toronto to LA
just what was he gonna man I wanted to
follow the guy at least he talked to me
not like that other [ __ ] the asian
guy that was on my last flight didn't
say [ __ ] i could have punched i could
have literally grabbed his nuts it like
lightly and like
waited for him to respond and he would
have just said nothing um yes so he was
living it up it was unbelievable
and I'm sitting next to the guy not so
living it up trying to [ __ ] do what I
do but I got the [ __ ] cod loin that's
kind of cocked to get the cod loin on a
[ __ ] plane you know it's pretty
[ __ ] [ __ ] to just get the fish on a
plane at all but you know what's funny
like I was really hungry before the
flight and they would look there was
sushi at the [ __ ] thing you know I
have some reason like I wouldn't get
sushi in an airport you know it's fine
I'm sure I mean yeah of course it's fine
but like I couldn't [ __ ] I wouldn't
do that and then when they when they
asked me they think I was like without a
hesitation I was like I have the cod
line like that's the sink it's on a
plane why is it worse or why is it
better
I still can't get over how [ __ ] dope
that people dress in Toronto though I
mean [ __ ] oh I watched this
[ __ ] thing on the plane called the
show called noisy which is awesome
I guess it's by like Vice land or
something and you got to watch this
[ __ ] thing it's about a dude or I
mean so it's always about like music or
some [ __ ] like one of them one of the
episodes was about like how music was
what one of them was about in music in
San Francisco in the Bay Area and then
another one was about music in Nashville
and the outskirts of Nashville and this
one dude I was like a rapper a 40 year
old rapper in Nashville that was like
selling CDs out of buses and he said he
sold over 2 million copies of CDs out of
his uh out of his bus out of his buses
and and and like nobody's done that I
like a street team like people like 86
they were saying 86% of CD sales or 86
percent of people don't buy CDs anymore
or something like that ever since like
2000 year 2000 or something and this guy
was out Hawking [ __ ] CDs and had like
a whole street
doing it and they get to keep calf half
the money the guys name is maverick that
was the the rapper named maverick um and
he would [ __ ] he would [ __ ] have
these these like these guys who were
like they were like I'll [ __ ] die
selling these CDs he was like he was
like so [ __ ] like he gave these guys
a second chance off the street to try
and like sell these guys CDs and like
give him a place to make money and like
some of these guys were addicted to
drugs or like they were like thieves and
they had like a second chance and this
guy but like wherever they go on to
these like outskirts areas of like
people places I have like one Walmart
though they think they're meeting like a
celebrity but wherever they go people
think that they're meeting a celebrity
because they take pictures and [ __ ] and
even though they don't know who the guy
is like oh yeah he's got the bus wraps
and all that [ __ ] and he sells some cds
for like 20 bucks and and but where they
go they're these like these these guys
that have like rough pass but wherever
they go they like they like end up like
getting into trouble sometimes like they
do drugs or they get in fights and [ __ ]
like this because they were all because
they're all like you know hoodlums or
whatever but they're they were [ __ ]
but this guy is at least this white
rapper who's with what there was a
cowboy hat and like race car [ __ ]
jackets and he raps and this other guy
was saying like it's a pyramid scheme
he's a piece of [ __ ] for doing this but
he makes the music I don't know the
noisy host guy was like tried to had to
try and sell the CDs with it with with
them and he said he felt bad doing it
and taking people's money even though
they were given our product it's like
buying a [ __ ] bracelet I don't know I
feel like it's like if you make the
music and you sell this [ __ ] like I have
guys come up into LA all the time always
like these young black dudes that are
just like hey man you like hip-hop and
I'm like yeah and they're like lips said
that should have said no it was like man
you gotta listen to my CD and like I've
bought one of those before and I
listened to it but it you know it was
like I don't know remember if I even
liked or not I was 15 years ago but like
these guys are trying to [ __ ] make it
like that I probably was probably
[ __ ] Kendrick Lamar for all I
remember and now it's [ __ ] I have
like now he's like if I can got 11
million followers on Twitter
um not was not Kendrick Lamar anyway I
[ __ ]
have fallen victim to that but whatever
I guess that's how it used to work right
there was no internet you just buy a CD
because you heard it was good
I don't remember you oh you'd leave
you've heard out on the radio right and
oh I [ __ ] off-track here but uh oh
those girls that [ __ ] my stomach just
made a noise very cool very cool
this is just the kind of real [ __ ] you
get at a in a podcast you know reminds
of that yem human did you have a good
Cinco de Cinco de Mayo I did am I going
to throw up with the [ __ ] going on
right now Cinco de Mayo I if you want a
drink drink you know but I don't like
when people need excuses to get drink
drunk it's a drunk right now
like Cinco de Mayo I just like white
people being like it's Cinco de Mario
let's do it makes me like just drink
it's Friday and just drink because you
drink may 4th - you piece of [ __ ] and
you're going to drink may 6th so don't
you because all we gotta do something
that's sad you Kuta that you coda all
right and also if you're gonna do Cinco
de Mayo fine but if you call it Cinco
did drink oh you need to buy a boat you
need to go out in the million jump off
the boat dude Cinco de drinko so dumb
so [ __ ] dumb like that's like such
white guy frat guy humor you know Cinco
de drinko basically anything that's as
funny as dressing up like a [ __ ]
something in a Halloween and then going
in and like dressing up for Halloween
that's how funny that is is to say Cinco
drinka was just as funny as dressing up
as a funny thing in Halloween and going
into a party and having everyone be like
oh and then that's it that's sad that's
sad
oh you're a guy that dressed up like a
chickadee Chiquita banana girl and then
everyone goes oh [ __ ] and then that's it
and then you have to stay dressed up
like the Chiquita banana
Halloween bike not worth it
so not worth it um man hey what the [ __ ]
are spinners by the way here's my 37
this showing but what is it you just you
know these things that people are
[ __ ] talking about online they're
literally just these gadgets that you
hold and you spin if you fidget I don't
know what that is
it's just a thing that is a that spins
around a lot of you guys aren't even
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
because I don't even know what I'm
talking about
but you just hold it in the middle and
then you spin it around and it spins a
lot and they're made out of like
skateboard parts or some [ __ ] but it's
like [ __ ] three inches big and you
can like put them on your head and watch
him spin or like put him on the ground
and watch him spin no I saw a guy
[ __ ] my producer was like no you just
hold it no I saw one of the locks put it
on Jadakiss his head and just he was and
he's bald and they just had him [ __ ]
here do her balance I get on his head
and it [ __ ] spun around
Jadakiss Sanat gangster yo dawg put that
spin on my head man yo you ain't think
I'm bout it put that goddamn spin on my
head it wasn't obvious Jadakiss or sheek
Louch or whatever the other one is
called that's obviously a very weird
name what is it
Styles P you know Jadakiss sheek Louch
and styles pay ah dude like how do these
guys get their names dude yo Jadakiss
hand me that spinner you'll get it from
Sal's P yo don't Sheik allow have that
spinner sheek Louch alone those names
are like huh he put that [ __ ] together
sheek Louch that's my favorite rapper
name sheek Louch what did he get it from
the locks
all of their things mean nothing unless
except it's their things
sheek Louch i love by the way I love
them sheek Louch this guy of course
sheek Louch has a bandana on and also a
hat pick one
Sean Devine Jacobs better known as sheek
Louch is a rapper member of the LOX and
founder of d-block records with Styles P
and Jadakiss he's 40 um how to get his
name though
also known as Donny G a man he's
rivaling up on the UH was a chief key
Chief Keef with all those [ __ ] things
names
sheek Louch Donny G Chris I used to want
when I was a kid I used to want my
[ __ ] I have thought about changing my
name today but one no-no when I was a
kid kid I wanted my parents to call me
crazy legs for real because I sat weird
at the dinner table
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I was six
hey mom will you call I legitimately
remember meaning it too I was like will
you guys call me crazy legs because I
sat funny at the dinner table and my dad
said no and I said why not I want you to
call me crazy legs he says because I
named you Chris and I said yeah yeah I
know but like it'll just be my nickname
and I remember meaning this and being
like you know but I please and my mom
was like no we're not calling you crazy
legs and I said will you just call it
call me crazy legs while we're at the
dinner table then and they agreed on
that but it lasted one [ __ ] one
dinner time because I like set up a
whole thing where I was like I'm gonna
ask him to call me crazy legs tonight
and then when we did and then they
called me crazy legs like once or twice
and they ended up call me Chris I was
like no , crazy legs and they were like
oh sorry crazy like dude what what
[ __ ] little [ __ ] are kids you know
like I really wanted my name to be crazy
like my nickname and then I wanted to
change my name when I was like [ __ ]
11 today me
in Monroe because I thought that that
sounded so cool because like Marilyn
Monroe is beautiful but also Damien was
like the [ __ ] dark like the another
name for the devil so I was like
together dude that's the [ __ ] what a
piece of [ __ ] I was just living in like
a [ __ ] three-bedroom house wanting to
change my name to Damien Monroe like
imagine if I did that how much I would
hate that
now comedian Damien Monroe oh my god
that's what rappers do but then they
just stick with it don't like yo but I'm
still Styles P and then he's 14 he's
like [ __ ] man I wish everyone just
called me Sean Chief Keef is like
[ __ ] 18 right now finally rich but
like in [ __ ] when he's 50 people are
gonna call him Chief Keef huh-huh no
spinners are gonna be gone in a week
though man by the time this podcast
comes out P we're not gonna know what
the [ __ ] spinners are these fads jumping
on the [ __ ] bandwagon and just it's
like so annoying dude remember pogs half
you don't remember pogs because you're
not old enough for [ __ ] six weeks
pogs were the [ __ ] and the good pods
were worth like [ __ ] tooth up $200
and I had some I got pogs and I would
slam them you set up a bunch of stacks
you set up some stacks and you try and
you have a slammer and then you slam the
stacks and whatever pogs flip over you
get to keep it was like a game it's kind
of fun a little bit but there were like
all sorts of pogs like x-men pogs
[ __ ] comic-book pogs those were a lot
it like mostly than their electro pogs
and [ __ ] and you would just get together
with your friends and do that if you
were bored out of your mind but it was
like a fad for a while [ __ ] pogs dude
I still have some pogs probably and
probably not I never had really good
expensive pogs though um but yeah these
fads do
that's what I'm hoping that these
[ __ ] things are like Coachella and
also Burning Man is [ __ ] but they're not
though they've been around forever it's
hard to come up with something that
[ __ ] state stays the course of time
you know what I [ __ ] actually
speaking of standing the test of time I
hung out with because he's in the movie
I'm in I'm in is with RZA and it was
like I was like geeking out dude I mean
I'm I love I love wu-tang but I also in
specifically love RZA and he's in the
movie and I was out to dinner with a
buddy of mine and then I got back to the
hotel lobby and the director the movie
was there and he was like he's foreign
but he was like hey do you want to join
and I was like sure he's like Bobby is
coming down and I was like Bobby and he
was like RZA he's coming down to hang
and I was like oh I just always in me I
always imagine a foreign person is lying
to me so I was like oh cool and I was
like he's not gonna come down but sure
enough he [ __ ] came down and I had
like dinner with RZA and we were
bullshitting back and forth like for an
hour plus dude we were trading like walk
or Road stories of course his were way
better because he knew Oh Dee be but um
ol Dirty Bastard but yeah we were like
[ __ ] telling Road stories and [ __ ]
back and forth which was insane to me to
talk to RZA about this like I mean this
is like a legend legitimately in hip-hop
he's like that the dr. Dre of [ __ ]
New York I mean this guy so anyway then
I saw the next day on set and I asked
him to take a picture which I felt like
a [ __ ] big idiot you know but I had
to cuz he's so cool I was like yo man do
you mind if I take a picture and he said
sure why not and he did like a karate
chop to the lens salut Tang but you know
and and I swear to God he looks younger
than me man black people don't age man
he looks [ __ ] younger than me I
looked like rize's [ __ ] dad's friend
like guys been
on forever any [ __ ] this is not fair
but he looked up and he was dope and I
couldn't I literally like it was it was
crazy to me that I was like sitting at a
table with Reza just bullshitting
he was asking he asked questions to me
about being a comedian I was like this
is are you [ __ ] kidding me it was
awesome
but identified it excels like didn't you
didn't you just do it to a show here in
Toronto like three weeks ago and here's
I don't remember and I was like dude
that's exactly how it is
but yeah that was one of those moments
where I [ __ ] geeked out all right I'm
going to check these uh
what do you call it
come on Twitter uh congratulations POD
hashtags i'ma check these out right now
I I mean come on man pod is this right
Gracchus pod yeah here we go oh did you
know what yeah this is actually a good
one from Kelly Joyner at Kelly a joiner
congratulations you got the name that
you wanted yeah I did notice this
actually somebody was tweeting me this -
I'm it was her jean-claude Van Damme she
says did you know what Jean Claude Van
Dam's real name is because I was making
fun of him last time about having a
Twitter his real name is jean-claude
camille francois van berenberg I mean
come on dude why so many names you five
people are you the chief keef of France
Jean Claude Camille Francoise van Viren
Berg then Varon Berg you know like not
enough for just Viren Berg but like van
anytime you have van in your [ __ ]
name like it's a saqqaq everyone
showing me the ting drinks I think
they're in London or some [ __ ] oh by the
way have you [ __ ] seen this [ __ ]
cat tongue thing that people put in
their mouths and lick their cats with
like you put it's like a rubber thing
Jack Boris at Jack Boris tweeted it at
may need your thoughts on this place
congratu
it's made from high-quality soft
silicone and it's for licking your cats
you bite it and then you [ __ ] lick
your cat and I guess it's supposed to
make your cat feel like comfortable
because they're their mom cats and dad
cats licked them yeah that's fine but
you're not a cat you're a just a guy
that's so weird you're not a cat you're
the cat's owner be the cat's owner hey
also why don't you [ __ ] paste glue
hair all over your body and go like this
you know sometimes even when your cat's
not around because you're you're a cat
now it looks so dumb I'm going to
actually tweet it here I'm going to save
it to my thing and tweet it in a little
bit I'll tweet it when I [ __ ] drop
the thing but uh this person made a
Twitter account just to see
congratulations pod that's very cool
thank you Colleen um
yeah don't do don't do okay here's
another one from daemon dis cistern @ oh
that's his hilarious his [ __ ] thing
is actually at change it underscore 100
very cool I like that very meta in a way
kind of who would you want in your dream
group text that's a great question dude
this is maybe the best
congratulations pod question I've had
what a great [ __ ] okay well
jean-claude van damme no doubt 100% him
for sure I'd want I'd want John Claude
Van Damme I'd want like I think I'd
honestly one chocolate Van Damme
Sylvester Stallone and Otto
Schwarzenegger to be totally honest and
then one person who like
love is like is like a hippie so we
could just like I could get all of those
action heroes thoughts on the hippies
and then also [ __ ] on the hippie with
like all of the action heroes and then
[ __ ] on the action heroes and see what
like the hippie has to say about that I
feel like that will be my Bill Maher
show but in group text I think that
would be great
and or like I would like to hear like
what Obama or Trump has to say about all
the things too
like maybe one of them because I guess
you can you can do a what do you call it
you can do you can have as many people
in a group chat as you want some people
don't like group chat texts they're like
oh do be me out of that [ __ ] I hate
group chat like [ __ ] that man what are
your thoughts on people who put ball
sacks on the back of their trucks from
Victor at slick vic 93 well obviously
you know what how i feel about that
that's really dumb if you put balls on
the back of your truck like that hang
and [ __ ] then and you're and you do it
to show what a man you are you actually
think it's cool you've definitely sucked
a guy's dick like there's no question
you've secretly sucked a guy's dick
because you're trying to be like the
most man dude ever that you've
definitely [ __ ] a guy so if you have
the ball funny fun ball kind of balls on
the back of your truck you [ __ ] a guy
and that's okay but you did that
okay so congratulations you [ __ ] a guy
everyone's tweeting me this too
that's so funny twitter twitter um yo
judge judy um someone's tweeting me
about judge judy Russ's liquor and
they're saying this guy has a bad
tattoos on his face which he does
because pretty much all face tattoos are
bad tattoos but dude judge judy if you
if you were to go on judge judy or like
what he like what is that what is it
like
so somebody I think somebody owes me two
thousand dollars because they [ __ ]
landscape to my place wrong so I take
the [ __ ] landscaper to court and I
[ __ ] I have to sit in front of judge
Mathis it's a TV show and then like the
judge Mathis is like hey man no youyou
owe them two thousand dollars and I'm
the landscaper I say oh well no because
this was just a TV show see you later is
it a real job I don't understand it's
entertainment judge it's entertainment
and I guess they're real judges so they
have to pay I really don't know about
that [ __ ] but Judge Judy every time I
[ __ ] think of Judge Judy I think of
the old commercial shirt where she was
like you have a job and the guy was like
no and she says gabon and then [ __ ]
hits the [ __ ] gavel dude that shit's
like 25 years old um I didn't mean if
somebody's asking me if I've been on the
Toronto subway I don't even know if I've
been on the what the Toronto subway I
didn't know they had won until like the
[ __ ] two days before I left this
person Eric Ellen Brooke would you
rather watch a fashion show full of Met
Gala fashion or conducted the Kentucky
Derby fashion that's a good question I
probably would rather watch well what do
I dislike more I probably disliked that
I don't know man
I dislike the Met Gala but at least
that's like raising money for [ __ ]
butts but the Kentucky Derby is just
like rich people showing off their
[ __ ] what's on top of their heads
like they did they like the Kentucky
Derby like with the [ __ ] hats and
[ __ ] and the dresses and they're all
there dressed up like that to watch
horses hi I mean write it so ya know I
know it's a horse race but why are you
wearing that at a horse race if you put
on a [ __ ] hat to watch a horse I mean
what kind of
we're rich person [ __ ] is that to put a
[ __ ] bug in via on the top of your
head to watch a horse imagine aliens
what if you went to Mars and we saw
aliens putting plants on their [ __ ]
heads to watch other animals we'd be
like whoa that's some crazy wood alien
[ __ ] these people look like [ __ ]
they have like front doors on their hats
and they're watching something named
here comes the show [ __ ] that that's
a horse named running with a [ __ ]
four foot two person on top of them dude
I mean how weird does it get is there's
literally nothing more white than that
to get a [ __ ] $3,000 a hat put it on
your head and watch a [ __ ] horse that
has the name of a sentence race with a
[ __ ] small person on top of it and
then to bet on it a by that's the worst
um so anyway I think I'm about to wrap
this [ __ ] up but yeah that's a crazy
[ __ ] thing next week I will talk
about the I don't know maybe the MTV
Music Awards although I don't think I
want to watch that
it's Sunday I'm recording this on Sunday
oh the KC zoo Erica Lane e en @ en el 13
the KC zoo has free roaming kangaroos
that sounds like the worst idea ever
not trying to get speed bagged by a
demon yeah dude that's crazy I hope
somebody gets [ __ ] up by a kegger I
mean I don't really hope it but I hope
something happens like we're kangaroos
scare somebody and then they're not
allowed to do that free roaming in a zoo
yeah animals though either I'm an animal
or they're not animals if there's free
roaming kangaroos and a zoo alright
that's it I'm done here thanks for
listening this has been congratulations
episode 15 next week I will have a lot
to talk about
I I'm keeping these podcasts coming to
you
if you can tweet about it
congratulations podcast or or you can
tweet to me revelations pod that's the
hashtag and you can subscribe that would
help and download the [ __ ] websites
and also tell people to listen to it
because I think over them [ __ ] keep
doing it if you don't do that [ __ ] I'm
not trying to threaten you but you know
got a lot of [ __ ] going on so I want to
keep doing this I like it if people are
listening so rate and review it that
helps subscribed on iTunes run stitch or
Google Play all that [ __ ] and my babies
thanks for listening and tune in next
time see you next week this has been
congratulations in podcast
[Music]